now go to second over my me we're second
year off the flow of the brakes don't
stop then stop in the middle of a lap
hello and welcome to Bruntingthorpe
today i'm here to meet the legend of
Ross Wilson he's going to try and teach
me how to become a racing he's gonna
have his work cut out though because I'm
an absolute shopping driver so I rock
tell me what are we doing here today
Lewis what we're gonna do today is we're
going to learn beat one of the fastest
racing drivers in the world we're going
to turn you in to a Formula One driver
so I don't mean to be rude what's this
then
well this you can feel what's going on
and when you're going into a corner or
and you're braking have a chance to
discuss it so essentially this is gonna
cover up all of my mistakes for that
it's gonna make them seem even worse
excellent ok we're good to go
this is a sort of speed I can cope with
this is this is a bit of me right now we
may pick it up just a fraction
[Music]
[Applause]
you're way too calm right now I'm just
gonna clean this is the one Oh where's
my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] now it's probably a
bad place to leave it alone
[ __ ] me this is [ __ ] scary two
million five [ __ ] have some of that
that was intense
Griffin stuff out there today what the
come bearing good news
five seconds which was the that was the
target time right at the time that gets
us on the grip man's taking corners at
100 mile an hour he's nothing and I was
squealing like a [ __ ] to be fair gone
[ __ ] [ __ ] proper job done
thank you so much mayor good yes we live
it